[Musik]
gernot hassknecht analysierten saarland
wahl im 119 sekunden
ich will ja schließlich nur um zahl amt
alte regel unrichtige war erkennt man
immer daran dass dafür nicht mal die
lindenstraße und verschoben
apropos wie fertig denn bitte klausi
beimer geworden andere geschichte
die saarland war was haben wir gelernt
erstens aller deutschen umfrageinstitute
müssen geschlossen werden sofort die
büros werden gesprächen die
meinungsforscher frieden hat vier alles
nur geraten
spd und cdu auf augenhöhe haben die vor
der wahl behauptet jetzt hat die cdu
fast elf prozent mehr
nach der logik bin ich auf augenhöhe mit
dirk nowitzki der deutsche wähler will
keine veränderung soll zwar irgendwie
gerechter werden im land war deswegen
dürften doch nicht die lippen
mitregieren dann muss ich ja mehr
steuern zahlen lieber alles so lassen
wie es ist
keine experimente viele cds zuschauer
haben ja bis heute die abdankung des
kaisers noch nicht richtig verdaut
und wer weiß denn ob man sich wirklich
verbessert mit was neuem klar ich würde
mich auch gerne scheiden lassen
aber kann ich wirklich sicher sein dass
ich morgen ein neues topmodell aus
brasilien in mich verliebt dann lieber
noch ein paar jahre renate kommt jetzt
und genau deswegen wählen wir deutschen
am 24 september auch achtung spoiler
die nächste crew und warum
[Applaus]